hi guys I'm Greg I am John so here's
what happened here I threw a
housewarming party today start at 6:00
p.m. no one showed up it was about 625
p.m. and I was like you know what before
anyone gets here I might have time to
shoot the Wonder Woman trailer reaction
so I shot it
spoiler alert I really liked it I
thought it was an awesome trailer and
then right when the reaction was done
the camera died and I didn't know how do
you know why he likes history I thought
I had a full battery and then I put the
card in after I filled my whole review
and I was like sweet I'm gonna get
what's up before anyone shows up right
when people start showing up I play back
the car was it was left in the card it
was all gone Oh God so right now it's
3:30 a.m. the party just ended it was a
successful party good part but Jon
Stewart here or Lima we're gonna watch
the Wonder Woman trailer John and you're
gonna give the reaction does the fate of
the Jack's arrest cement very much I'm
drinking I really liked it I honestly
thought it was an awesome trailer I'm
like I'm actually excited I know you
have a lot of doubt for the DCE you and
held it so yeah blue watery the goals
gave us many
one day you'll know them all this is
where we keep them beautiful who is me
isn't only the fierce the moment even
good and that is not you who dying
oh not me here right now you will train
hard the mini Amazon before him and if I
times harder oh [ __ ]
but she might never know the truth but
what she
[Music]
both laughing what is this - for you
maybe the worst favorite duty to defend
the world where you are what a mortgage
do you think whoa I'd imagine anyone
else we defend the wolf dilemma what we
regard all of them here yeah it's not
for everybody
whoa
[Music]
whoa intuition
right now while anyone
I'm sure
[Music]
and I know sincerity quality in any
volatile
[Music]
[Music]
yep that's my good work please put the
sword down it doesn't go with the outfit
at all
God you wear DC have you easy does that
laugh at sometimes what do you think
that's pretty sweet trailers yeah well
like um this seems like it can be their
thoughts you know I can see that yeah
here's what here's what I was feeling
when it was done why I was so excited it
was the first time a trailer for any of
the DC EU movies where I was like holy
[ __ ] by the time I was done I realized
I'm invested in Wonder Woman right I'm
invested in Diana yeah I like the whole
like I was setting up her character like
you can't be this person because but
really they're like trying to keep her I
mean I saw the Wonder Woman cartoon yeah
and so they're trying to keep her or you
know like you know don't let her powers
unleash too much hey there we go there's
something in her that's really great but
we can't let it happen
hahaha but you know like when Wonder
Woman being called it what she feels a
calling to go help the world like go
fight in the war yeah
doubt I was actually feeling that I was
interested in her it wasn't just oh this
is another cool visual stylistic trailer
from the DC EU I found myself going up I
want to see this woman's story told you
know and I feel like none of the
trailers have ever done that for me of
any of the movie yeah yeah totally well
it doesn't say like that's the odd thing
about these DC movies is like you know
they're our track record and spotty
lately but every time they put out a
trailer like this like a there's
something interesting to talk about and
like this has a lot of stuff that
appeals directly to me like this is
going to go into what is that world war
1 yeah one more one and it's also at
least a shot that I I don't know what
that realm is called but you know like
that those Y tablet on him yeah yeah it
was like white cliffs and the ocean and
like this their their actual homeland
like I love stuff like that so this
looks really cool on that for a nice gal
gadot in in Batman V
I might not like that moving despite
loving what they did with her character
overall I still enjoyed her and I know
some people you know I know some people
go again are their Wonder Woman but I
you know being not very initiated into
the world of Wonder Woman this looks
cool to me like I hope they nailed it I
feel like this is about a hero this time
yeah that's one one thing is the run one
of the co riders is a guy who's like
responsible for shows like the flash
right now and you feel a sense of hope
from the character of Wonder Woman good
it goes in your neighborhood I do not
get that into jail I guess if someone
who's like fighting for something great
what before saying you shouldn't do it
no I have to do what I must do um I
guess it's a [ __ ] superhero like
everything else we got it I like it's a
superhero this time but it doesn't where
it's going full crazy wood like this
makes us up much brighter movies so has
you know rather darker lighting
throughout but I still feel at its heart
in its core it's a story of hope and
here with them yeah I do get that vibe
inand I'm happy to put these Leah's
finally decided maybe to work those
principles in dad because yeah you know
you need at least some of that in a
superhero movies and then I feel like
for a Wonder Woman for her first
feature-length movie yeah you [ __ ]
need that yeah yeah well I have an ideal
world I think it would be really cool if
they can nail dis movie a Wonder Woman
can be the one out to gate worth like
yes now we're on track now we got that
right like I keep hoping those those
remarks that were made about like all
things happening on so Wonder Woman like
I hope that's not true I hoped it well I
would go as well I had a couple articles
on Collider one one was how they saw
like the one of the first one of the
main battle sequences and they said the
way it all played out leading up to the
battle and the actual battle itself was
amazing okay I remember they saw actual
like edited footage of it okay they said
it was amazing and you felt the best in
Wonder Woman so it's good it's okay if
you're nodding in the middle of my
monologue it's 3:45 morning or something
yeah bring it and you're like saving and
they also and I read it like a long
interview they have a
Jenkins you know hell yes and David she
was saying how they surprisingly they
let her do primarily what she wanted to
do for this one like she says she spread
a lot of reports about how like you know
DC's like controlling all the time maybe
it was like that for the other films
what she said for this film they really
let her do what she wanted to do I hope
so yeah
and I mean I hope so good Ruby man yeah
and I and I do hope I know it's a
hit-or-miss thing to do but that's the
one thing I've always liked about DC's
mission statement with theses you know
we want at least we aspire to get
interesting directors to head these up
and to let them have their vision a
little more than just doing our own
committee
Marco Boyle and I like that on principle
so if that's true I'm super happy about
that you know penny Jiang is the same
Wonder Woman was a factual character she
loved growing Haley I would read the
comic so she understands Wonder Woman I
liked the way she was breaking down who
Wonder Woman is in the time period and
everything it was like well she really
understands a long-ass interview and she
really understands what makes Wonder
Woman work hell yeah all right oh yeah
you know then this is all this is all
making ya that much more excited about
it because like I said it's called
Wonder Woman origin trailer and we're
seeing the origin story and Wonder Woman
being told and Beyond like a lot of the
DC trailers where it's like cool visuals
really well edited trailers and stuff
and kick-ass action this made me feel
like I'm already like I want to go to be
heard and the DA her story didn't make
me excited for the world and for the
time and for yeah the story of Wonder
would like he's dead later chemistry
with a crisp I'm looking really good
yeah yeah the the whole her and Chris
Pine and I forget her name was the woman
from from from Shaun of the Dead and
stuff and from Marin like that that
little trio that dynamic like it should
be a lot of fun and yeah you know I like
I hope this I'm excited about this
because this is another opportunity for
you know female-driven
mr. breakthrough because yeah you know
ultraviolet didn't do the trick and Aeon
Flux didn't do trick it would make up it
would be [ __ ] awesome in such a
statement and it's like a weird way if
Wonder Woman was the first film the DCU
like for the majority felt got her right
yeah it like this to be about a few
that's like a female-driven cast that
would be probably cool like it Wonder
Woman can prove it and be like no no no
no no no we got yeah I would be so
thrilled for them I would be over the
moon about that like well yeah so I
didn't get this up earlier guys I
explained the problems at the beginning
of this video to do the channel you can
subscribe real reject we want to see
Wonder Woman are you happy yeah follow
John on Instagram and Twitter at reason
to join he goes to the social media
manager of love house and the real
rejects and I want to eat my food now